[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
the prime minister is pushing ahead with
the next stage of unlocking england's
coveted restrictions despite a warning
that the indian variant could lead to a
substantial resurgence in hospital
admissions
the scientific advisory group for
emergencies says there's a realistic
possibility
that the coronavirus variant first
identified in india
is 50 more transmissible than the one
which emerged in kent last year
but while the government accepts the
variant could delay plans for the fourth
stage of lifting lockdown
on the 21st of june plans to relax rules
on monday
are set to go ahead iva bennett reports
it was all going so well outdoor dining
about to become indoor
lockdown so nearly unlocked monday's
easing of restrictions will still go
ahead but the final phase in
june is now in doubt the prime minister
warning the indian variant could pose a
significant obstacle
on our road to freedom i have to level
with you that
this new variant could pose a serious
disruption
to our progress and could make it more
difficult to move
to step four in june in bolton where the
new strain is spreading fast
extra vaccines have already been bust in
while across the country
second doses will be brought forward for
the over 50s and clinically vulnerable
cutting the gap between jabs from 12
weeks to 8
in a bid to combat the surge scientists
fear the new variant could be 50
more transmissible than the strain which
emerged in kent
known as b117 we expect
over time this variant will overtake and
come to dominate in the uk
in the way that b117 took over and
indeed other variants have
taken over prior to that four people in
the uk are known to have died with the
indian variant while cases have nearly
tripled in the last week
it's prompted the scottish government to
alter some of its route out of lockdown
already
glasgow and moray will stay with level
three restrictions on monday
while the rest of the country drops to
level two england's strategy though
for now is to watch and wait this is
absolutely a moment to be watching and
doing
really good shoe leather epidemiology by
the public
health teams to understand is this
transmitting in households or not
the evidence at the moment seems to be
that um there's more transmission
amongst people who have
recently traveled but not otherwise so
we've really got to hold down over and
watch this space for about the next two
or three weeks
nervous times for not just politicians
but the public and businesses too
everyone hoping one step forward doesn't
mean more steps back
iva bennett sky news
let's take a look now at the latest
coronavirus figures for the uk
there have been 2193 new cases
recorded in the most recent 24 hour
period
17 more deaths have been reported which
means the total number of people who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
now stands at 127 668.
another 209 284 people
have received their first vaccination
and 428 041
received their second in total 55.4
million jabs have now been administered
across the uk
also this morning israeli planes have
made renewed airstrikes in gaza in the
early hours of this morning
with hamas militants firing rockets back
an israeli strike on a house in gaza
city killed at least
seven palestinians the highest number of
fatalities in a single hit
so far meanwhile israel defense forces
posted these pictures overnight
claiming rockets were being fired
non-stop from gaza
this they said was the result when a
rocket hit the city of ashdod
they warned the attack won't go
unanswered
more than 9 000 israeli troops now are
amassed
amassed on the border with gaza as
international efforts to stop the
conflict spreading across the region
has stepped up the israel defence force
claims more than 2 500 rockets have been
fired towards israel's commercial
capital tel aviv
killing eight israelis israel has
launched extensive strikes claiming to
be targeting a network of tunnels
it says are being used by militants in
gaza
the palestinian authority says 11 people
died in the west bank
yesterday and the total number of people
in gaza is at least 132
since monday across the country clashes
between israeli jews and israeli arabs
have continued in several cities
including jaffa and lot mark stone
reports from the west bank
on an uprising that shows no sign of
ending
after the heaviest night of bombing this
place has ever experienced
it is a wonder jamal at nasia is still
here
the family house had only recently been
built
it was home for the whole nasir family
30 of them lived here
everything is still here she says all
our new belongings
but now destroyed what will we do now
this whole neighborhood has been
destroyed but they still look for what
might be left
in a place where nowhere is safe the
hospitals give some
cover many spent the night here
but are told they must leave they're too
busy with the injured
this woman asks why again this is
happening to them
and then close by more
the israeli government says this level
of destruction is necessary in the
defense of the nation
2 500 rockets have been fired from gaza
at
israeli communities since monday night
more in a week
than in years combined before and the
israeli military has told sky news that
the purpose of all this is to destroy a
network of tunnels
a thousand kilometers of them where
militants hide
with their weapons the prime minister
remains defiant
they attacked us on our holiday they
attacked our capital
they sent missiles to our city they are
paying
and they will pay a heavy price for it
it's not over yet
we will do everything to restore
security to our city
and our citizens but in the other
palestinian enclave the west bank we saw
how this week has stirred something deep
with burning tires for cover and with
rocks in slingshots young palestinians
said they were defending their land
the israeli soldiers hit back with live
rounds and with tear gas dropped from a
drone
among the protesters here a 27 year old
who didn't want to reveal his face
first of all i need to hide my face
because of my mom
if she sees me then she'll kill me not
the israelis
in the clashes was a moment to hear his
motivation
people who live in palestine know that
palestine is
is a a big and a huge
jail cell basically we cannot move we
cannot do anything so
i think this is a normal reaction for
all the suppression
can you go to jerusalem and of course
not
i i've never been to jerusalem and it's
my dream to go there
mustafa baguti is a former minister in
the palestinian authority
what you see here is unity between
palestinians in the west bank in gaza
ship
in in the diaspora in jordan in lebanon
palestinians and lebanon have been
trying to enter the borders and come
here
and what you also see here is
unprecedented unity with palestinians
who live inside the israel in 1948 areas
the drive to the other west bank towns
takes you past jewish israeli
settlements
which have this year expanded at an
unprecedented pace
and passed israel's security barrier a
wall and offense
the length of the enclave in bethlehem
the israeli military passed through the
wall and fired tear gas at the
protesters
but it is the clashes within mixed towns
in israel itself which has caused the
most surprise
this is kawakama in the galilee
the israeli military is stretched across
the country
back in gaza the united nations school
is another place they hope will provide
some safety
but in such a densely packed place with
no way of leaving
this is gaza today mark stone sky news
in israel
let's get back to our top story now and
scientists have warned that the
indian variant of the coronavirus is
expected to become the most dominant
in the uk the health minister edward
argo joins us now good morning to you
uh in light of the rise in the number of
cases involving the indian variant
in this country how confident are you
that
the government should be pushing ahead
with easing restrictions
on monday in england well as the prime
minister said yesterday we are confident
that easing restrictions on
monday is the right thing to do and is
the safe thing to do
but as we look towards the 21st of june
quite rightly
we're looking at the evidence that's
emerging day by day
around key aspects of how the so-called
indian variant behaves
the moment there's no evidence that it's
either resistant to the vaccine
or that it's more more dangerous or at
least more severe illness but what we
are looking at
is transmissibility and how much more
transmissible this fight this variant
appears to be so we're doing the right
thing for monday but we're obviously
keeping everything
under review for the next five weeks
before the decisions made on the 21st of
june
now the key words there at the moment
and sage has warned that lifting of the
restrictions could cause
a substantial resurgence in hospital
admissions
are you simply ignoring that advice no
the advice the prime minister received
advice from sage
and others and considered all that and
on the basis of that advice
he is clear that it's the right thing to
do to ease restrictions
on monday it's being done in a
proportionate way
we all have our part to play in behaving
responsibly as that happens i'm
following the rules on things like
mark wearing but we're not seeing at
this point in time
even in areas like greater manchester or
bolton any significant change in number
of hospital presentations
or admissions i understand in bolton
there's been a moderate increase
in hospital admissions um but that's in
a group as i understand it from the
hospital there 35 to
65 year olds and the vast majority of
those representing people who haven't
had
the vaccine and that's the key element
here that changes
um where we are today and why we're
relaxing
on monday the restrictions compared to
where we are say
three months ago four months ago but but
the latest modeling
shows that there realistically is a
possibility that uh the indian variant
has a 50
higher transmissibility rate than the
kent variant
um so why take the risk
well the short answer from that is the
modeling is still being done so it
doesn't show
um 50 percent increase for certain what
it we do know as chris whitty said last
night in the prime minister's
press conferences we know it is it has a
higher transmit ability
but we don't know whether that's a
marginal increase in transmissibility in
which case
it wouldn't in any way fundamentally
change the picture
we're seeing or whether it's a
significant increase which would then
of course as the prime minister said
lead us to consider what's the right
thing to do
in advance the 21st of june but we're
doing that work now we won't know in
truth probably for another week or two
the uh the firm answer to that question
and do we categorically know now
that the the vaccinations on offer
currently to people
sufficiently protect against the indian
variant where we are today on that is
there is no evidence
at the moment that suggests either that
the vaccines are ineffective against the
so-called indium variant or that this
so-called indium variant
is more severe in the illness it causes
or that there is a greater risk of
death but again we're looking very
carefully at that over the coming
a couple of weeks we'll get more
information on that but
it's always a challenge quite rightly
coming on a program like this and
answering questions when there are still
some things
we don't know but the prime minister did
the right thing he wanted to level with
the british people yesterday on where we
were with things
even recognizing there is still work
being done before we have a completely
clear picture
of that transmissibility he did the
right thing he wanted to to level up
with the british people about where we
were on this
um you're bringing forward second doses
for
those um over 50 what what's the the
logic
behind that because it it does seem that
those that are already
um have received a first vaccination
have some protection wouldn't it be
wiser
to look at younger people those under 40
as they are
perhaps transmitting the the disease
more often
well what we know is that age as chris
whittie said yesterday chief medical
officer
age remains the single biggest
determinant of
likelihood of severe illness or severity
of illness if someone catches
the disease and we know that first doses
give significant protection but that
second dose
gives greater protection and much longer
lasting
protection so we think it's the right
thing to do to reduce
that time scale for second doses from 12
weeks to
eight weeks for those in cohorts one to
nine the over 50s
to make sure they get the maximum
possible protection from these
vaccines and for the longest period and
that is the most effective way of of
preventing or
reducing significantly the risk of
severe illness and death
sadly from this disease in terms of
the indian variant was india put on the
red list soon enough
i think i lost your final few words
there on the sound jillian but i think
what you're saying was
um was the timing right or wrong in
terms of
uh india going on the the red list at
the end of april
i think when that decision was made all
of the evidence and considerations were
weighed up and i believe that the right
decision was taken but it's important to
remember
whether in the red or amber category
this country has some of the
toughest border control restrictions
in the world to keep out this uh disease
so if you're
in the amber category for example you've
got the
test before traveling you've got the two
and eight day tests you've got the
quarantine
at home um and of course uh
if you're in the red category you've got
the managed quarantine that's a
whichever category you're in that's a
pretty strict
regime which is checked up on by border
force officials and others to make sure
people are
complying with it so i think in a sense
the key thing here is how robust is that
regime
whichever category a country is in and i
would say it's one of the toughest in
the world
uh just finally i wonder if you can give
me your reaction to this serious fraud
office launching
an investigation into suspected fraud uh
this is to do with the gupta family
uh alliance which have had uh dealings
with uh green silk capital
um it won't surprise you know from my
days back in the
ministry of justice as a minister i tend
not to comment on
ongoing or live investigations either by
the police or by the serious fraud
office so i hope on this occasion
you'll forgive me for not commenting on
that and let them get on with their work
edward argher thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning jillian
time for a look now the morning's other
main stories and rough sleepers in
england will be helped into
accommodation with the government
saying more than 200 million pounds of
funding will provide
up to 14 500 beds the money which will
be used by
councils charities and other local
groups will also fund
2 700 support staff
the government says it wants to continue
the help it's given to homeless people
during the pandemic
rail companies are to add more than 2500
daily services to timetables
ahead of the next relaxation of lockdown
restrictions
the rail delivery group says it's the
largest increase in capacity this year
the changes will come in
tomorrow debenhams is to shut its last
remaining stores today marking the end
of its 243-year history on the high
street
the department store chain which
employed more than 20 000 people before
the pandemic
sold its brand and website to online
giant boohoo in january
but confirmed its high street shops
would close for good
let's take a look at the weather for you
with nasa i'm smiling but
it's gray it's wet i know
it's pretty much the same as the last
few days in fact
pretty much what we've been experiencing
so far in may is
likely to continue for the rest of may
let's take a look at today's forecast
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning i'm beginning to sound like
a broken record aren't i
rain or showers for many areas today and
it's going to remain cool for much of
the weekend
cool for the time of year that is so
currently we are seeing outbreaks rain
across northern parts of ireland
starting to nudge into northern ireland
wales parts of the midlands central and
southeastern england elsewhere there are
some
showers but for most of scotland it's a
mainly dry start
going into this afternoon that rain will
be moving its way northwards and as it
does it starts to break up into some
showers so they will spread up towards
parts of northern ireland
south west scotland northern and eastern
england where there could be some pretty
hefty downpours and for the rest of
england as well as wales
and ireland although that band of rain
moves northwards
yes it will brighten up but there will
be some heavy showers
in between and some of them could be
sundry with a risk of hail
for scotland apart from the showers
across central and southwestern areas
actually it's not looking too bad
particularly across the far
north there will be some sunshine
although for shetland and oakley it will
be quite damp
and also murky there for much of the day
it's going to be a cool day especially
so along the south coast with the breezy
conditions there so
pretty wet pretty cool for today
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
welcome back israeli planes have made
renewed airstrikes in gaza in the early
hours of this morning with hamas
militants firing rockets back
the escalation in violence comes as
palestinians prepare to mark what is
known as
nakba day 73rd anniversary of their
displacement from the territory
that became the state of israel in 1948.
well our foreign affairs officer deborah
haynes joins me now from
jerusalem uh deborah just bring us up to
date with what has been
an escalation in violence overnight
yes well there's been more israeli
airstrikes into gaza
and a volley of rockets fired from gaza
back into israel i think you might be
able to see some footage that the israel
defense
forces have released of rockets being
fired at the
mediterranean coastal city of ashdod
and also footage of the latest
israeli israeli airstrikes i mean this
is a
clashes that have gone on to their sixth
day now
um many casualties in gaza in particular
over 130 dead
more than 30 of them children and it's
that
death toll that really is ramping up
diplomatic efforts or putting pressure
on the need for diplomacy to try to
bring an end to this
violence to these hostilities everyone
very worried that we could be descending
into
some kind of all-out war and also this
is not just a conflict that's happening
in gaza um that we're seeing
anti-anti-israeli
protests taking place across other parts
of occupied territories in the west bank
and also um interestingly on the border
countries in jordan
in lebanon there were reports yesterday
of three rockets being fired
towards syria towards israel from syria
and here inside israel too
widespread unrest between arabs and jews
prompting fears this could even trigger
a civil war and like you said today
is always a highly sensitive day it's
called nakba
the catastrophe it's the time that the
palestinians remember
the day after the the creation of the
state of israel
when hundreds of thousands of them had
to leave this country or
or were forced to um to leave and
you're going to see protests they take
place annually
this year they're bound to be far more
charged people will be watching whether
that triggers yet more violence yet more
responses
from israel or can diplomacy work one
final point to make
the us sent a senior diplomat to the
region he arrived yesterday
in israel he is there to try to help
broker some kind of peace agreement the
egyptians playing a very key role
as well as the united nations and
tomorrow for the first time we're going
to have
a un security council meeting taking
place
in the open can they have an effect can
they agree
on a united front that's that remains to
be seen
deborah for the moment thank you
five years ago simon grey lieutenant
colonel in the royal marines died of
esophageal cancer aged just
38. since then his wife emma has set up
a group
which supports military spouses and
partners who are running their own
businesses
throughout it all she's been supported
by the royal british legion
today the organization marks its
centenary with the ceremony at the
cenotaph in london
as well as in other towns and villages
across the uk
let's speak to emma now who's at the
cenotaph this morning
good morning to you emma um start by
first of all telling us what the royal
british legion means to you
good morning yes and it's an absolute
honour to be here the lord british
legion do an amazing job
and not just here today thinking about
the last hundred years but also thinking
about the hundred years and
years beyond then hope to come it's an
absolute honour to be here
uh tell us about your husband who you
sadly lost in
2016.
um well he was my soul mate and my
children's father and uh he is
absolutely my inspiration
he was
ironically never mind on remembrance
remembrance was a day where he would
set aside to think of his comrades
and it will always be a day where i
think of him
and all those who have served our
country and
help us to live the life that we live
and you weren't just a military wife you
have a military background yourself you
served in
the territorial army i believe
yeah just for a short while i did
something called
otc which is officers training corps
when i was at university
and and then it seemed natural to go and
do
a little territorial army santos course
and go on and join a unit in london
but then i met my husband and i also
decided to change
a career to do law and ironically
study end of life and do wilson probate
so my life seems destined to be one
where
it's brought me here today and now
you're
training to be a grief counsellor
i am yes life's given me a reality check
and i want to use both my legal
knowledge and
the mental health knowledge that i'm
gaining on the counseling course
and see if i can help others who might
have a
similar sad fate my mother used to say
that death and taxes were the only
certain things in life but during my
legal career i understood that not
taxes don't necessarily get paid by
everybody so death is the only
inevitable thing happening to all of us
it's absolutely heartbreaking and
anything that we
both individuals who are counsellors
professionals and the british legion and
milspo the group that you mentioned can
do to support people who've been through
something like me
is amazing and what exactly will be
happening today to to mark that the
center
so today i believe that what's happening
is i'm going to be one of the
replayers and we are recreating what
happened 100 years ago
when the royal british legion was first
started so that's a
hundred years of the royal british
legion being marked today thank you so
much for speaking to us
emma gray thank you
the green party is hoping last week's
elections have set them on a path to
become the third
largest party in england the party
gained another 88 council seats in
england in last week's local elections
taking its total to 151
in bristol they're now the joint biggest
party alongside
labour they also saw record-breaking
results in london
with sean berry coming third in the
mayoral election ashna huranag reports
now on the party's surge
across the country rising through the
ranks to become the joint biggest party
in the city of bristol
for the first time these green party
councillors will take their seats in the
chamber
as the main opposition it's been
overwhelming
both locally and just as a green in
general because
um there's been so much success in other
places
but it was always bristol that i had my
heart set on
they are now the largest green
councillor group in the country with
many of the 24
snatching seats in traditional labour
strongholds
the green's success in bristol is really
no surprise to many people here this
is a city that's championed
sustainability and cycling initiatives
and has been
at the forefront of the climate change
movement it was here
on this street that greta thornberg
marched 15 000
people on a climate strike last year
it's a movement
that is driving greener politics it's
not just
sort of looking at the ecology side but
it's making a more equitable society for
everyone people
planet other countries i've been voting
for quite a long time because i am well
probably one of my biggest priorities in
life is is the environment
and that no one else is really doing
enough about it
i generally probably wouldn't vote green
in a in a maine election
um for an mp but i think you know
generally at a council election
there's an opportunity maybe to show us
dissatisfaction at the
the major parties bristol is part of a
wider green surge
eight scottish green msps also gained
seats
helping make up a pro-independence
majority and there's also been success
in sheffield and manchester too i think
there's an element of people looking for
something different
and also looking for something positive
and i think
the green party are providing that
positive element
this confidence only propelled by the
party's co-leader coming third in the
london mayoral vote
a warning to their competitors to no
longer dismiss them
as a wasted vote we're now the third
party across
many parts of the uk and i think people
are looking to vote for something
holy positive something that's full of
good ideas not just as a protest
but as an endorsement the greens across
england and wales remain small in number
but there is growing confidence in the
gains made in cities like this
for a party determined not to be
underestimated
ash naharinak sky news in bristol
time now to take a look at the weather
with naz
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning rain or showers for many
places today
in fact for the rest of this week that's
what we're looking for uh
lots of spells of rain some showers that
will be rather heavy in sundry and
it remains cool for the time of year as
well currently the rain is across parts
of the north of island into northern
ireland
spreading across parts of wales midlands
central and southeastern england and it
will head its way
northwards through this afternoon it
will tend to break up as it does into
showers
some of them could be quite heavy across
northern and eastern parts of england
later
meanwhile the rest of england as well as
wales and ireland yes will brighten up
after quite a dull start to the day but
there will be some showers uh around as
well some of them heavy thundering quite
slow moving too
for the southwest of scotland there'll
be some showers but i think for the rest
of scotland mostly fine and dry except
for shepparton and orkney it will be
quite a murky and cool
damp day there
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
back with us now to take us through the
newspapers uh journalist freddie
mcconnell and former editor of the daily
start dawn nissan welcome back to you
both
starting with the telegraph dawn uh and
this story
about prince harry uh in the news again
what fall this time yes julian this is
the
ongoing fallout from the podcast
that prince harry did during the week
with our um it's called the armchair
expert podcast
um and it's obviously during mental
health awareness week and he was talking
about his mental health
however in talking about his mental
health he managed to
again completely forget about the mental
health of his dad and his grandmother
who are still
grieving prince philip let's not forget
um
harry was saying that he wanted to break
the cycle of genetic pain
um and the royal family was like living
in the truman show and living in a zoo i
mean basically he was throwing his
family under a bus again
um and this is the fallout this is
continuing with the story in the
telegraph today and i do
trust the telegraph on royal maps they
do have seem to have some pretty good
contacts out
and this is the the royal households
reacting saying they are the left
reeling
by harry's podcast and one senior aide
has said it was unnecessary cruel
um and for a couple of assume that
paintings just about their compassionate
principles
they seem woefully lacking now look i
mean
is it critical or is he sharing his
truth
in in the context of mental health
awareness week
look of course look he is entitled to
talk about his mental health issues and
his problems but i think the way he did
it julian
was unnecessarily cruel i do agree with
it with the telegraph story
coming from the role you know to his
father and his grandfather now
there's an interesting background to
this story because prince philip himself
once did an interview i think to david
dimbleby um about his own mental health
issues in which he said
his own upbringing um and about gordon
stone and you know his relationship with
his father
wasn't great so there is a real
president of this so you sort of
understand
why how he's done it however prince
charles has always regretted that
interview especially in later years when
his relationship with his father
improved
so you would have thought that harry
might have learned from those
lessons about you know about being a
little bit
more thoughtful about what you're saying
about your own family
okay freddie take us to the the mirror
the the headline there
hell in the holy land
yeah i uh and this is just obviously
heartbreaking on every level um
seeing the violence that's occurring in
israel and palestine at the moment
i wanted to highlight this piece in the
mirror because i think it's a rare
example
of i mean without wanting to sound
cliche
you know the human side of what's
happening um whenever violence
flares in the middle east uh in israel
palestine
we start this sort of back and forth
about you know
hamas on this side so many casualties in
this side so many casualties on the
other side
and it just sounds like a script and i
think um as soon as people hear it
they tune out um so actually you know we
need these kinds of
insights um and it's just
yeah it's just heartbreaking to hear
from a 29 year old dad
called yusef hamash saying um that the
only way to keep
his three-year-old calm is to tell her
that the explosions are just fireworks
they've had to relocate four times in
the past couple of days
um but it's you know also important to
hear um
an insight from the israeli side a woman
called danielle bett saying
um you know as they're sheltering that
they're thinking of the people in gaza
and it's not a competition everyone's
paying is legitimate i think
you know i spent a lot of time in israel
palestine um at university
and this reflects the kind of
sentiments i would hear fear
confusion on both sides i mean obviously
also you have the right-wing
perspectives in israel but um
yeah just it i know i know it's also
cliche it's more complicated than that
but ultimately it's also not because you
just have people here suffering
and a key line though to express the
fact that everyone's pain is
is legitimate and and the article
looking from both
both sides to the times dawn
this is about uh weddings um
being able to go ahead but no dancing
what's a wedding without dancing
yeah i i honestly julian
the world just when you think it can't
get any murder it actually certainly
does well as of monday with the
next step in our lockdown um wedding
guests
um you're allowed to have 30 people at
your wedding as opposed to 15
um but and dancing is no longer banned
oh right
now it's advised again yeah and
um and dance floors are closed so how
they're going to do this julian in your
average wedding venue like a hotel or
something you know how to get a
hazard tape around the dance floor you
don't go near it and also in this list
of instructions somewhat hilariously is
like
you can't dance on the dance floor and
nor can you dance on the tables and
chills we're banning that as well and
it's like
how realistically is the government
gonna stop this it's frankly a bit mad
however julian the good news is that the
government is going to allow the bride
and groom to have their first dance
together i was going to
say you can't stop the first dance
that's like stopping the experience
freddie tell us about this um story in
uh the
independent about an agrophobic pregnant
woman
and um a judge has had to make a ruling
so i saw this story uh last night and i
was
um horrified i i can only assume
that there is more context that we are
lacking it seems
on the face of it that a judge has ruled
that
this woman who has agoraphobia
does not have the capacity to decide to
have a home birth
and i think that's a terrifying
uh set of circumstances that this woman
could find herself
in um i'm not sure how someone with a
mental health disorder like agoraphobia
could possibly lack the capacity to make
that kind of a decision and i think it
speaks to a wider cultural
misunderstanding and fear
of home birth as a as a safe option
um that studies show that there are
fewer interventions in birds that
take place at home versus those that
take place in hospital
so the idea that having a home birth for
anyone is less safe
uh it's just that they're just not true
the medical reasons why
she needs to be in in the hospital i
mean i haven't got the full article
that's the reason there may be and that
but you would think that that would be
reported if
if that was the case um that obviously
she's anonymized so there's
no necessarily risk in identifying what
the specific
circumstances are and that's what makes
me worried
that it's simply uh a fear of home birth
as a
and and taking away of this person's
right to decide
[Music]